good morning believe nation today's
message is stay focused over to you Tony
aluminum so entrepreneurs who are
listening frequent shot on straight to
the point entrepreneurship is a long
time Johnny stop seeing it as a
short-term or long-term Johnny great
companies create an accomplished
entrepreneurs did not make it in one yet
didn't make in three years is a long
time journey so moving dare to dream
implement your dream and stay focused
this is a message especially true for
entrepreneurs because I think we
generally overestimate what we can do in
one year and underestimate what we could
do in a decade and if you talk to most
entrepreneurs and you look at them at
the one year mark and you ask them is
this what you thought you'd be almost
everybody says they felt like they would
be further along in where they are now
look at your own example look at your
own path to your own struggle your own
journey has been an entrepreneur did you
think it was gonna be this hard did you
think that you would be further along
than where you are right now or did you
kind of meet your expectations almost
all the time people feel like they
should be further ahead than where they
are right now in that first year time
frame the key though is that you stay
focused that you keep working that every
day you keep building the business you
keep grinding and eventually that
momentum starts to carry you forward by
doing work every single day eventually
the momentum takes hold I look at my
youtube channel now I'm having you know
lots of success we're getting almost a
thousand subscribers every day I
remember trying to build my first
thousand subscribers like one subscriber
a day was amazing and you know insanely
good but the momentum started to happen
for me when I started creating more
consistent content and I started making
videos every week every week every week
and then every day every day every day
the real growth came when I started
going to a daily schedule instead of the
week the same thing will happen your
business if you're doing something your
business
once a week the growth would be really
really really slow where if you're doing
something every single day or two times
a day or three times a day right you'll
start to see the growth come a lot
faster and the problem is most people
quit too early most people and if you
look at a YouTube channels an example
most people quit after their second
video or their third video or their
tenth video that's not enough you have
to make hundreds of videos to get good
at it and to build momentum and so most
people quit in their business too soon
most people quit after done doing a lot
of hard work but there's still a little
bit more to go before you hit that pot
of gold then you start hitting your
curve and getting on that momentum
bandwagon and so the key thing is that
you stay focused on the journey it's
going to be hard expect it to be hard
it's part of the process you might get
discouraged you're not where you think
you should be stay focused on the dream
and if you keep going that momentum will
lead you to success so the question they
today is I'm curious for you guys at the
one year mark or if you're not quite
there yet in your business are you where
you thought you would be or did you want
to think you kind of be a little bit
further ahead be honest be honest share
some love put in the comments below I'm
gonna join a discussion finally went to
give a quick shout out to Keith Washoe
from Keith Washoe calm he's an author
i've had them on my website for a
hangout as well has a great new book
that's out so i recommend checking that
out Thank You Keith Thank You Keith for
buying a cup of my book it really means
a lot to me that's why we're getting the
shadow and if those you watching if you
want your chance at a shout out in a
future video make sure to pick up a copy
of the book email in your receipt so we
can keep track and seeing the bonuses to
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day it seemed to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot events pressing away
more this prey so give me go